this year's graduates are entering a
booming job market with more open jobs
and unemployed workers that sounds good
right in our continuing series work in
progress we've partnered with LinkedIn
to take a close look at issues affecting
the workforce LinkedIn CEO that's Jeff
Weiner recently gave the commencement
address it is alma mater
that's a Wharton School at the
University of Pennsylvania his message
was be compassionate I vowed that as
long as I'd be responsible for managing
other people I would aspire to manage
compassionately and I can tell you with
absolute conviction that managing
compassionately is not just a better way
to build a team it's a better way to
build a company Jeff Weiner welcome back
to the table
great to have you here you said that
that was the best advice that you would
give your 22 year old self and that
struck me because with all your
knowledge experience and success that
was it be compassion I think that that
advice should go regardless of whether
you're 22 people of all ages need to
hear this message and why was compassion
the big about the best advice for you I
think is a younger executive I go back
10 or 15 years I was expecting people to
do things the way I did which is kind of
human nature you know we're all
egocentric and we all see the world
through our own lens and if you really
want to lift people up and inspire them
and help them to be their best I think
it requires thinking about things
through their perspective and
understanding their objectives their
hopes their dreams their fears and
working with them and doing everything
within your power to set them up to be
successful and when you do that when you
do that when you do that it's you're not
only setting them up to be successful
you're setting the team up to be
successful you're setting the company up
to be more successful you're setting
yourself up to be successful you said
it's hard to do Jeff it's I find
incredibly difficult to do and in that
clip you showed one of the key words was
aspire I aspire to manage
compassionately because it can be so
difficult to get out of your own head
and be a spectator to your own thoughts
especially when you become emotional
good successful companies have core
values that everybody understands how
did you put that value into practice
yeah it's a great question so it's one
thing to codify your values and I think
increasingly companies are thinking
through
what their first principles are it's
another to actually walk the walk and so
for us at LinkedIn it starts with the
recruiting process and not lowering or
compromising the bar in terms of our the
importance of our values that continues
on with onboarding and the first day
someone sets foot within the company
we're going to start to help educate
them on what's most important to us and
not only what we're trying to accomplish
but how we're trying to accomplish it
which i think is increasingly important
we do learning and development around
our culture and values we evaluate
performance around culture and values
what about taking it from the other end
of the telescope say I work for somebody
who shows none of those things I think
it depends on personal situation I think
it depends on the company I don't think
there's any cookie cutter model for this
and to be frank there's companies and
there's leaders who've had extraordinary
success with not managing compassion you
also talked in your speech about the
growing economic divide and tribalism in
the job market what do you mean by that
and how how that really is changing the
world we live in today yeah two
different components of this and why I
believe that compassion will grow in its
importance one is widening
socio-economic stratification the the
gap between the haves and have-nots here
in the States is hovering near
historical highs and when you have a lot
of wealth concentrated amongst the
smaller group of people and you have
broad swaths and segments of the
population that don't feel like they
have equal access to Economic
Opportunity no matter how hard they're
working it's bad for the economy because
they can't afford products and services
it's bad for society because they feel
disenfranchised so interesting to see
the LinkedIn's data shows the number one
skill lacking mo markers is
interpersonal or soft skills how's that
impacting the job market so there it's
interesting because a lot of people are
fixated on technology and rightfully so
it's an increasingly important part of
most companies and how they do business
but what we found when we did our skills
gap analytical work is that
interpersonal skills the gap there is
roughly three times higher than software
engineering in the United States when we
talk about interpersonal skills we're
talking about skills that anyone can
develop and acquire talking about
communication reasoning team
coordination jobs and customer service
sales development business development
education all require those kinds of
skills you say anyone can acquire them
but where
go acquire them if you're somebody
looking at the job market and given the
shortages in the job market now how long
is gonna take somebody to do or take the
job market to catch up with the jobs
that are needed right now yeah so
thankfully again it's not just these
technical skills that could require
longer periods of time to develop these
kinds of interpersonal skills you can
pick up in classes that are online
increasingly and it's wonderful to see
that there's a rise in the amount of
courses being offered and the number of
providers who are increasingly thinking
about where the jobs are and will be and
the skills required to obtain those jobs
but we're also hearing there's a surplus
of jobs but employers are having trouble
filling them yeah we have an answer to
that
according McKinsey roughly 40 percent of
employers in the United States are
having trouble identifying prospects
with the skills they need for the jobs
that are already available so these jobs
increasingly exist as a matter of fact
there's nearly 7 million roughly 6.7
million available jobs in the country
and there's 6.4 million people who are
unemployed so we all need to do a better
job of aligning the supply in the demand
and if you're on LinkedIn that can help
you find a job LinkedIn is pretty good
it is very good as very good Jeff
Fleener thank you so much it's good to
have you here in great graduation speech
- yes